[Applaudissements]
regardez bien le prof
il est exceptionnel il est magique c'est
pour vous c'est sûr dit
[Musique]
ce matin là nous assistons étonné à un
cours du professeur jean marc vallée des
pyrénées
parce que la normalité c'est de la merde
c'est de là on a commencé avec le kronum
en trou duc toi la danseuse là moi moi
qui d'autre mais froid irait peut-être
noir trou duc trou a maintenant je peux
pas et tout va bien pourquoi c'est
facile quand ça nrj12 troupe du p'tit
écrit au tableau merde je me demande si
je marque je vois pas bien le tableau
d'ici là quoique très vite un coup de
trop moi j'arrive pas c'est trop dur
pour moi
onair il trompait d'affairé tu dégages
vas-y gros bâtard
[Applaudissements]